hey guys I just got done with the last
big event here for youtubers in New York
and I have so many thoughts running
through my mind I recently just like
word vomited onto Twitter about my
thoughts and how inspired I was by
seeing all this it's impossible to
describe because I was trying to come up
with the words to say my feelings on the
way here and I just couldn't because
like just at the end of the day I was in
a room with so many youtubers that I
look up to and respect and I know and I
got a chance to meet him and I got to
chance to interact with him and I got a
chance to work with him and it was just
so amazing to see all of their
accomplishments paraded on a big screen
for everyone to see and I was like
honored because I was among them I was
on the screen like they they showed me
up there with them in the gaming crowd
and it was just it was so phenomenal to
see and I cannot wait to go back home
just so I can work on cool videos I met
so many people that I respect deeply and
like adore and like I can't help but
word vomit about it because I just can't
stop thinking about how much I want to
do cool stuff and I'm trying not to be
too loud because I'm in a hotel there's
other people around here trying to sleep
it's late at night but it's just like I
had to make something to tell you guys
how much this means to me
and how much it means to know that
people out there and I went up and I
talked to people youtubers that I've
respected and some of them even knew me
and even if they didn't know me they
gave me the time of day because it made
me realize that all these people they're
just people and they started from
nothing and they created something
amazing and it was celebrating the
communities that they engaged with in
the communities and the fans that they
loved and how much they interacted with
people and it resonated with me so much
because I love the community that we
have built together I love you guys with
all my heart because I know the things
that we have done together in the things
that we can do together like a thing
everything that we do is amazing and I
want you guys to know that as inspired
as I am and that's going to be so much
cool stuff coming out in the next few
weeks in the next few months in the next
few forever of my channel there's going
to be so many cool things coming out
but I just want you guys to know that I
need you to believe in yourself I need
you to tell yourself that you can be
fearless in whatever you do because so
many speakers were there telling about
their life experiences and how much what
they did matter to people and how much
it mattered to themselves just knowing
that like what they did mattered and
they started from nothing and even if
you feel like you've got nothing on your
side and nothing going for you even if
you feel like your idea is stupid or
your passions don't matter that is a lie
to tell yourself to go the easy route
and that's why I will tell you until the
end of my days I believe in you guys and
I know that what you do matters and your
dreams matter and your passions matter
and once you find something that you're
passionate about you burn for you need
to pursue it with a reckless abandon
because people will tell you that you
can't for as long as you're trying to do
something and they are wrong but nothing
could be more wrong than actually
believing them so just know that you
guys can do whatever you want to do you
guys can do absolutely anything and it's
not just me that needs to say it you
need to say to yourself but you also
need to remember that you're part of
this gigantic community you need to tell
your friends and family people who are
struggling trying to accomplish their
goals or just get by or whatever they're
doing they need to know that you're
supporting them and one of the best
things to come out of this was just
realizing how much the community on
YouTube means to people and how much it
means to people like me and other
youtubers out there who know that their
communities are everything to them
so take some time and I really mean this
I really mean takes some time and tell
someone you know or tell a complete
stranger or tell someone else down in
the comments below that what they're
doing matters and that you know even if
they don't believe in themselves right
now that a complete stranger can support
them and they can do anything that they
want to do so long as they don't stop
believing in themselves and that's I was
like don't stop believin the song never
mind
I am just completely out of it
I know because I've got so many things
in my mind that I want to say and at the
end of this day like this may seem
stupid when I go back and look at this
but I just had to get my words out my
thoughts out because I'm so ready to get
back home and I'm so ready to work on
stuff and I'm so ready to be out of this
hotel and get back home so I can scream
to reckless abandon like I usually do
and not try to be quiet for other people
around here but just thank you guys so
much for doing everything that you have
done from me and just remember to spread
some love to everyone else in this
community because if we have a community
in a society where everyone believes in
each other just like that guy believes
in me with the siren but if we have a
community that believes in each other
more than they believe in themselves we
won't need to worry about people failing
because they can keep trying and
whatever they do and they may not
succeed it the first thing but so long
as you guys don't give up you're gonna
make the world the difference and
there's someone out there who's gonna
make the next big thing and they need a
push right now and I got the bike out
one hell of a push being out here and I
got one hell of a jolt of inspiration
and God
but either way just thank you guys so
much for watching thank you guys for
listening to my late night ramblings yes
I do have glitter everywhere I was doing
a slo-mo thing and a big party it was a
lot of fun you'll see soon just thank
you guys so much for being there for me
and please be there for each other
because this community is a shining
beacon of hope and that's not an
exaggeration that's not hyperbole that's
not saying something to make you feel
good about yourself well I hope it does
but I'm not just saying that you guys
are an amazing community I want you guys
to believe in each other as much as I
believe in you so that's about
everything that's all my thoughts for
now I'm sure I've missed something I'm
sure I'm I've woken up neighbors at this
point already just cuz that's how I do
so thank you guys again
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye